[Music]
good morning
my name is dr ganesh taylor and i'm a
scientist
who's here to tell you this morning
about something called crispr
now some of you might have heard of this
already and be wondering what it is
and i'm hoping that that's why you're
here to learn about it
and but before i get into the sort of
hot and heavy business of the science
i'd really like to start with asking you
a question
do you remember the first ever iphone
i mean i know that i certainly do so
back in 2007 the first
iphone dropped and those of you who
remember this moment in time
we'll remember that it completely
changed the way that people used
phones right mobile phones existed
before
but you know no one had seen anything
like the iphone this was something that
you could do phone calls on you could
take pictures
it had these things called apps it was
wild
okay so what's happened since that point
well of course nowadays we all know
that uh the iphone has evolved
um and if you google something like
iphone evolution you'll come across this
right and you can see how over all of
the years it's completely changed and in
fact
quite a few of us i mean maybe i'm
starting to show my age now
but you know the latest iphone i was
just thinking you know
why can't this just be like the original
the original did exactly what i wanted
it to do
so why am i telling you about this well
just like the way the iphone changed the
way mobile phones
um were used how they felt to users
and the kinds of capacity that they
brought to the table
of mobile devices that hadn't been seen
before
that's kind of how crispr is so
what is crispr crispr is something
called
a genome editing technology right
and it's a two-parter so what you can
see in this picture
is a piece of dna in blue and then the
sort of two parts as it were of the
crispr section here so the crispr
bit is the is the sort of purple and the
and the red section
and the cas9 which is the sort of
technical uh
full title of this technology crispr
cast 9 the cast 9 is the sort of purple
blob bit behind
it so it's a two-part
system crispr cas9 that kind of makes
sense it has a two-part name
genome editing technology so
when people ask what is crispr what
they're actually asking is
you know what is genome editing
technology
and genome editing technology is kind of
what it says on
the can so it's a type of molecular
technology admittedly
and that is used to edit
the genome and why did i draw the
analogy between
iphones and crispr well because types of
genome editing technologies had existed
before
basically but when crispr came along it
completely changed the way scientists in
particular
use genome editing technologies to to
edit genomes
so like all cool technologies crispr has
evolved
and evolved in quotation marks it hasn't
sort of done it in the classical
biological sense it's been
it's been done by other scientists it's
been developed like a toolkit
and so you can see here another
schematic that i just knocked up
that shows how this was the original
sort of crispr system which was
actually lifted from um another system
it was used in bacterium
classically um and it's used by bacteria
to defend against viruses and it has all
these multiple parts
and when scientists realize that you
could use this to edit genomes
essentially
it started to get sort of polished
refined and you can see here in
the first sort of step of that these two
little
separate bits of um molecule or rna if
you're interested
and became uh basically available to
scientists as just a singular strand so
you know simplicity simplifying making
the tool more usable
and since that point so this is this is
the type of technology that most people
are talking about when they're talking
about crispr cas9 you buy in
this sort of purple strand and and
then you load it into a cast nine but
actually there's loads of other versions
these days so you can see some
schematics here and this is just a sort
of
tip of the iceberg of variants of this
technology that are available
you can have bits attached that will
bring in other molecular machines that
can
either light up pieces of dna of
interest
turn them off turn them on so that
reminds me to say something that i
haven't said explicitly so far
which is related to what happens here
right
implicitly in what i've just been saying
is the fact that this purple strand here
the crisper part
is that it is programmable so
that is basically what made crispr so
much better than all the other genome
editing technologies
before scientists used to just sort of
throw molecules at genomes and hope that
they would
you know have the intended effect and
check if they had or hadn't
but the point is this crispr portion of
the crispr cast 9 system
is programmable so you literally as a
scientist can just
type in the sequence that you want to
target and then you can send the cas9
there
which is great it's like find and search
search and replace whatever you want to
use basically
so that's crispr okay it's a genome
editing technology it's a two-parter
and one of those two parts is
programmable and that
gives scientists the ability to edit
genomes in locations with
precision that was previously not
available before
bit like how the iphone changed how we
contact other people in our network
so why am i telling you all of this and
why does it really matter
well and this slide is just here to
remind me
to remind you of something that is very
underrated i think by most people
in their day-to-day lives so i'd like to
take us all right back
to a really really important moment in
our lives
um which was fertilization
so i'm i'm not sure that i can ever get
this point across
with enough ore um that i feel about
this sort of stuff
but i'm gonna try anyway so this is the
moment here
or a schematic representation at least
of the moment
where the sperm from your father met the
egg of your mother
and what happens in this moment and what
this moment represents is one of the
sort of most amazing paradigms of
biology realistically speaking
right which is the fact that we all
started life off
as a single cell okay
just one cell with one genome in it
okay just take a moment there to
appreciate that you
as you are this morning all the many
trillions of cells that you are
that i am essentially are all derived
all came from this one cell at the very
beginning
okay and this really matters
if you think about it in the context of
what we were just talking about
okay so the the information that is in
that genome
that one cell okay is the information
that tells that one cell
divide grow make organs
become this tall right it's going to
have brown hair
it's going to have ridiculous brown eyes
it's going to be female in my case right
all that information is within that
genome and
additionally in that genome is
information or or
sort of codes that can
inadvertently encode for things that
might go wrong in the future
for example we have diabetes in my
family likelihood is that i actually
have some variants in my dna
that make it more likely that i'm going
to end up with diabetes one day
right all that information is found or
stored in the genome of that first ever
cell
and is propagated through every single
cell that has made up my body
makes up my body today and has made up
my body throughout all of the 30
odd something years that i've been on
planet earth so this is kind of like
the hymn sheet of the chorus right
everyone sings from the same him machine
so that's the biological equivalent
and what that means in terms of crispr
cas9 genome editing technologies is that
if you wanted to change the dna
of a cell with precision you can do that
now
right and if you overlay that onto
the fact that all life every organism
starts off as one cell means that you
have the opportunity
to change what that genome looks like at
the point
at which any embryo is a at the one cell
stage
and that modification will stay within
those cells
as they develop okay so
this is my really ridiculous schematic
now to remind me to sort of now start
contextualizing this
a little bit further right so who really
cares about this crispr cas9 technology
and really why do any of us
properly care about the fact that you
know we started off life as a single
cell
well i hope i sort of inspired a bit of
awareness
about the fact that you know gene
genomes are really important
and it's amazing the fact that we all
start off as as a single cell
but also the fact that there's
significance to that right
so medical significance so
who cares about crispr cas9 well the
reality is when the papers came out what
was it 2014
um the people who cared about it most
were the scientists right people like me
in the lab when we first read
when you know when i read the paper
during my phd i was like
whoa this is going to change things my
supervisor the same
you know we were all having
conversations about this technology
and why is that well because to continue
watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas